the movie starts off in 2020 where two
armed soldiers pass through the Dark
Forest of Fortune Island an apparently
abandoned island in the middle of the
Pacific Ocean they are seemingly hunting
for something suddenly something in the
darkness catches their attention causing
them to scream in fear meanwhile halfway
across the globe Mr Gary gaw the owner
of ocean Airlines proudly inaugurates
the first flight of his luxurious new
passenger aircraft a390 he has invited
famous celebrities and people from the
media as VIPs for the grandiose launch
of his Cutting Edge aircraft before the
flight takes off Gary emphasizes to his
operations head Peter the importance of
flawless execution especially when it
comes to serving the billionaire Prince
kza of Saudi Arabia their potential
investor Peter assures Gary that he has
arranged for the prince's favorite pop
star to be on board ensuring a positive
experience for the influential guest the
journey kicks off in Rio with great
anticipation and a grand Fanfare is
planned for the aircraft's arrival in
Hong Kong among the VIP key passengers
are the billionaire Prince Coda from
Saudi Arabia popular pop singer Colin
award-winning Hong Kong actress Lily
Young retired American sports star
Rodman distinguished journalist Mia ran
along with her cameraman Bob from
international news web celebrated situ
in Chef Mr Leo and the acclaimed blind
cellist Kim wam little do the passengers
know Gary and ocean airlines are facing
severe financial difficulties Gary has a
hidden agenda he plans to secure Prince
cat's proposed investment during the
flight in a desperate attempt to rescue
the company from its Financial woses
just before takeoff Gary learns that the
pop star Peter had invited is none other
than his estranged son Colin the
fatherson is not on good terms because
Gary wanted Colin to pursue business he
wanted his son to be the heir of his
business not an Entertainer it turns out
that Colin followed his own path
eventually achieving his dream to become
a celebrated singer in the world it is
also revealed that Prince katza and
Colin went to yales together and are in
fact close friends Gary is seemingly
Furious by the fact that his good Forno
son has been invited for the maiden
voyage he even warns his son to not
cause any trouble because this trip is
very important for him and the company
in the cockpit pilot Jason along with
co-pilots rucken and xang diligently
readies the aircraft for takeoff they
meticulously go through the pre-flight
checks ensuring that every instrument
and system is in optimal condition Jason
with years of experience communicates
clearly with his co-pilots discussing
the flight plan and weather conditions
Wen known for her attention to detail
reviews the safety protocols while Xiang
monitors the communication systems to
ensure smooth coordination with air
traffic control after switching to
autopilot mode rixen checks the lounge
area and discovers that Chef Le fell ill
and couldn't join the flight in his stad
an American named Mike has been sent as
a replacement to prepare Chinese cuisine
G soon learns about this and once again
reprimands Peter for not handling the
matters properly as everyone relishes
the various amenities on the L urious
flight the aircraft suddenly navigates
through a significant thunderstorm over
the Pacific it soon encounters a
lightning strike but thankfully it
doesn't damage the critical systems of
the plane concerned about potential
damage the crew advocates for an
immediate Landing to inspect the
aircraft Captain Jason after examining
Communications with the control tower
affirms that the current route navigates
one of the Pacific's least stable areas
this Revelation only heightens the
urgency of the situation initially Gary
driven by his desire to reach Hong Kong
in record time opposes the crews plea
for an immediate Landing he instructs
them to continue the journey at all
costs he also asserts that the a390
being the epitome of commercial Aviation
sophistication demands the crew to
devise a strategy to navigate through
the storm and ensure they reach their
destination as scheduled if they do not
follow his orders then the debut for his
sophisticated plane which costs him a
million dollar would all be a big joke
soon after as the plane encounters
turbulence within the thunderstorm
various systems display discrepancies
the turbulence ride also triggers
warning lights in the cockpit Captain
Jason tells his co-pilots that the
heightened turbulence may impact fuel
efficiency necessitating an emergency
landing after some discussion Gary
eventually consents to the crews request
to land the plane on the supposedly
uninhabited Fortune Island this decision
is driven by the need to assess whether
there is any severe damage resulting
from the lightning strike to discreetly
execute the emergency landing and avoid
attracting attention gar opts to disable
the plane's location tracker despite the
intense storm the crew skillfully guides
the a390 to a successful landing on the
island while the passengers are
instructed to remain on board rixen and
Captain Jason venture outside to inspect
the aircraft's engines Jason observes
some mysterious scratch marks on the
outer structure of the plane so he
orders co-pilot xang to run a diagnostic
thankfully there is no internal damage
and the plane can be fully functional to
reach Hong Kong as they prepare to
reenter the cabin r bucken notices that
journalist M Ren and her cameraman Bob
have left the cabin without anyone's
knowledge on the other hand miren and
Bob are filming the island when the
ladder suddenly stumbles and Falls when
he prepares to grab his equipment he
discovers a human carcass terrified he
urges M Ren to return to the plane
however she insists on taking video
footage of the corpse suddenly an
unknown creature attacks Bob from behind
and kills him instantly Luen comes to M
Ren's rescue and the two women fall on
the ground in order to avoid the attack
from those creatures just then a vehicle
approaches from behind the dark jungle
and the people on board it start
shooting the mysterious creatures which
turn out to be mutant cats in the
meantime a multitude of black Shadows
jump out of the Bush and kill Captain
Jason when rsen and mien are about to be
ripped to shreds by the creatures the
approaching vehicle saves them
momentarily on board the vehicle are two
armed soldiers Lieutenant Vincent Rigs
and Sergeant Nikki Lee swiftly
approaching the soldiers attempt their
best to kill the mutant cats which are
only growing in numbers after learning
about the situation Gary instructs Peter
to close down the hatch and hurries Zang
to start the plane engine just when
Peter closes the hatch the chef
substitute Mike arrives at the scene
punches Peter and reopens the hatch on
the ground ruen and miren are running
towards the aircraft and this is when
they discover the lifeless body of Jason
they then hurriedly climb up the hatch
ladder saving themselves from the
monsters below likewise the armed
soldiers having killed numerous mutant
cats climb up the stairs and
successfully lock the hatch once inside
the plane the soldiers claim to have
been sent by the UN Army to eliminate
the monsters that are inhabiting the
island they had been held up in a
warehouse for the last 2 weeks when
suddenly they heard a plane landing
nearby for 2 weeks they fought really
hard until they two were the only
survivors chef Mike who used to be in
the Special Forces suspects Vincent and
Nikki are not who they say they are is
suspicion only grows when they learn
that the communication equipment had
been damaged during their last takeoff
now that the a390 radio communications
system is badly damaged Vincent suggests
rerouting the flight to an army
coordination point in the Pacific he
claims that the coordinates lead to a
Transit airport under the ocean offering
supplies and repairs despite Mike's
doubts about the accuracy of the
coordination points both ruen and Gary
dismiss his concerns meanwhile a series
of bad things keep happening one after
the other first Peter follows Vincent
and Nikki to the restroom where the
latter two are discussing their ultimate
plan there he learns their true IDE
identity it turns out that the soldiers
are not a part of UN forces instead they
are here for a personal reason they have
collected a sample of the Mysterious
Island and are planning to sell it to a
buyer who is located in the coordinates
provided earlier when Vincent finds
Peter overhearing them he swiftly takes
care of him Peter's dead body is then
kept in a closet which is later
discovered by rixen and the rest of the
crew meanwhile back in the main Lounge
area an air hostess hysterically
announces that the famous Hong Kong
actress Lily Young is dead at first
rixen and the crew suspect retired
sports star Rodman of being involved in
the actress's shocking death they
interview him citing past knowledge of
his behavior when intoxicated it turns
out that Rodman struggles to control his
emotions when he's drunk and he appears
quite Tipsy at the moment amid growing
panic and Rebellion from rixen and Mike
Vincent and Nikki ultimately unveil
their real motives hijack the plane and
take everyone hostage they claim to be
heading to a retired Nimitz aircraft
carrier but what's worse is that one of
the mutant cats has made it to the
aircraft during the last takeoff
apparently the actress and some of the
hostesses were killed by The Vicious
creatures when they were on the lower
deck Vincent and Nikki then take the
rest of the passengers on the upper deck
and threaten them to stay put the crew
is then forced to obey their
instructions and land on the said
coordinates however Xiang confirms that
there isn't any land nearby so Landing
is impossible Vincent forces him to look
properly and this is when a huge carrier
is revealed in the middle of the ocean
the ship turns out to be the biggest
aircraft carrier in the world despite
multiple attempts rixen skillfully lands
the plane on the carrier in a dramatic
fashion clipping the wing in the process
just when the passengers are instructed
to get off the plane the mutant cat
appears on the upper deck thankfully it
turns out that the creature is repelled
by music so the blind cellist plays his
instrument until most of the passengers
make it out of the aircraft safely
although most survivors make it to the
ship's deck the damaged a390 slides off
and sinks into the ocean sadly Zang also
dies during the process while rucken
manages to cling onto the ship's safety
net Mike then helps her to climb up
safely following this Vincent instructs
Nikki to keep an eye on the hostages
while he Ventures below deck to locate
Dr Han the scientist has promised
Vincent a hefty sum of $10 million for
the soil sample from the cave where the
creatures reside however when he enters
the ship he only discovers Eerie silence
the absence of other people on the
carrier adds to his unease Vincent
eventually locates Dr Han who discloses
that his experiment on on the creatures
spiraled out of control the creatures
mutated wiping out everyone on the
carrier and are now multiplying Han
shares that as a final Resort he
engineered the carrier's nuclear power
engine to detonate and destroy the
experiment and the creatures realizing
the explosion would jeopardize his
chances of claiming the promised $10
million Vincent rushes to prevent it
however on his way to the engines he
confronts Mike who managed to slip away
from the deck a heated confrontation
ensues between the two machos as they
wrestle and full capacity during the
flight Mike manages to grab Vincent's
gun and aim at him however he is unable
to open fire because it reminds him of
his pass he has flashbacks of wartime
and dead soldiers he served with while
he was in the Army seizing this
opportunity Vincent regains his gun and
prepares to shoot Mike just then a
mutant cat slashes him from the back
rendering him dead on the spot Mike gets
hold of the gun again and successfully
kills the creature before heading out to
warn others in the meantime ruen and the
others managed to subdue Nikki she then
locates a helicopter nearby and
instructs the survivors to board it by
this time a 100 mutant cats make it to
the deck and begin chasing the group
while rixen prepares the chopper to
leave Colin and the cellist make use of
their music to temporarily hold back the
creatures suddenly the cello stoed
playing due to a failed string the
mutant creatures are now more vicious
than ever as they prepare to feed on the
survivors thankfully Gary arrives with a
huge flamethrower ignites it and burns
the approaching creatures following this
rucken successfully starts the
helicopter and the survivors manage to
get on it Mike makes his way back up to
the deck and narrowly jumps onto the
chopper as it leaves the ground sadly
Gary sacrifices himself to hold up the
mutant cats his last words to his son
remain never sell the ocean Airlines as
the helicopter flies far away from the
carrier a huge mushroom cloud arises
from The Horizon moments after the
carrier the whole experiment and the
creatures are destroyed when the carrier
engine self detonates the movie ends
with the survivors promising to go on a
vacation where there are no cats in
mid-credit scenes however a mutated cat
is shown to be hiding on the helicopter